mel gibson hasn't exactly had the
smoothest couple of decades he's got
something of a controversial past to say
the least
including numerous allegations of racism
bigotry
and domestic abuse although there was
once a time when any mel gibson film was
pretty much
guaranteed to draw a crowd that's not
really the case nowadays
and it's clear that the acclaimed actor
and oscar-winning director star
has fallen very far indeed yeah you want
to see crazy
nonetheless gibson now looks to be
making strides towards a comeback the
internet is awash with praise for
gibson's latest movie appearance
in boss level a sci-fi action hulu
original
gibson isn't the film's lead and he
wasn't behind the helm as its director
either but fans and critics alike are
absolutely loving the flick
with some taking special note of his
performance by all accounts boss level
is a fun
and gleefully violent action film that
joins the ever-growing list of movies
who have utilized
the time loop story trope frank grillo
probably most familiar for his role as
crossbones in the mcu
stars in boss level as roy pulver a
special forces soldier stuck in an
endless time loop forced to relive the
day of his death over and over again
meanwhile naomi watts plays roy's
estranged wife gemma and her boss as a
defense contractor colonel clive vento
played by gibson himself in the midst of
roy's many time loops a suspicious death
puts ventura on his radar
and from there the two are set on a
collision course filled with all the
explosions car chases
and gun fights that you could possibly
hope for now it's true that both casual
movie lovers and professional critics
seem to agree that gibson's new movie
isn't exactly breaking new ground
when it comes to the time loop sub genre
that said boss level is still unique
among such films for just how fun
and unapologetically bloody it can get
as a result of plenty of viewers have
taken to twitter to praise the new
sci-fi
action flick one user told their
followers if you like stuff like
groundhog day
russian doll happy death day to you then
check out boss level on hulu
meanwhile another twitter user called
the movie a hugely entertaining time
loop action film
bloody and inventive with his tongue
placed firmly in cheek
that same user also pointed out that mel
gibson ought to have been given a little
more to do in the movie
which is pretty telling praise in a
world where many would agree that les
mel gibson
is definitely better than more putting a
little smack talk twist on their praise
for the movie
another twitterer said boss level is
like if guns are kimbo was good
and although they didn't give a full
verdict on the movie itself one user
highlighted the sheer bloodiness of boss
level
and especially frank grillo's endless
gory deaths writing
my theory as to why frank grillo made
bust level to the throne sean bean with
the most on-screen deaths with just one
movie
surprisingly enough it isn't just the
fans who are loving boss level either
while the film's current rotten tomatoes
score of 72 percent indicates that not
all critics loved the movie
it still managed to garner some pretty
noteworthy critical praise
at indy wire critic christian blavald
wrote that grillo gives boss level the
thing most video game movie riffs lack
a pulse while gary goldstein of the los
angeles times said
boss level takes a well-worn gag and
injects energy
showing the genre is still a game worth
playing writing for den of geek bernard
boos said of the movie
it's a lot of fun to watch and one of
the best showcases of grillo's very
particular set of skills yet while
deciders johnny lotus was more
economical with his words
writing simply it's outrageous just go
with him
so it really does seem like boss level
might be something of a surprise hit and
at least some of that is down to mel
gibson himself
just what it means to his troublesome
career however remains to be seen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one